she was left for it to go terminal that
shouldn't have been the case Donya and
Claire are friends and they're also
cancer patients Donia is in remission
Claire has advanced melanoma that has
spread to her bones and her lungs they
both feel Claire's cancer could have
been stopped if she had received quicker
care my anxiety I felt that I was going
to take my life at one stage and I said
this too there's so much
and no one was helping me
and I said I've got two children
but they've just left me and I know that
there's a lot of people out there that
is in the same boat
she's right the latest data shows people
are waiting longer for screenings and
referrals for some types of cancer the
number of people aged 50 to 70 screen
for breast cancer in the past three
years is nine percent down on
pre-pandemic levels it is a different
story for bowel cancer though thanks in
part the campaigning efforts of Dame
Deborah James who died at the end of
June with more than seven in ten people
being screened it's actually the highest
rate it's ever been up 12 and the number
of people referred by the two-week route
which means they've gone to their GPU
with symptoms and their GP has given
them an urgent referral is also up it's
13 up on pre-pandemic levels but let's
look at the wider picture in 2022 to
2023 so far
22.4 percent of people had to wait more
than two weeks after being referred by
their GDP to see a specialist cancer
consultant and right now the target is
seven percent so it's three times more
people having to wait over a fortnight
to see see someone I spoke to Dr Julian
Alford from the Royal College of
Radiologists earlier he said the
pressure will increase
essentially however you boil it down
there is too much work to do and there's
not enough Workforce so no matter what
we do in terms of trying to diagnose
cancers and trying to get cancers
treated that's for diagnosis that's
radiographers to actually look at the
scans and Radiologists such as myself to
interpret the scans there are not enough
of us and then when patients who are
diagnosed with cancer knee treatment
we're also short of oncologists to to
undertake that specialist treatment mid
and South Essex NHS Foundation trust
said there had been no delay to Claire's
care and that it was offering her and
her family help and support the
statistics are dispassionate but they're
made up of thousands of stories some of
them like hers Tom Cheshire Sky News
Gray's Essex